Hé ! Cyp' ! On fait un TOP 10 des jeux de l'année ?
Non, j'ai arrêté les jeux vidéo. Je suis un adulte maintenant, tu vois ?
Mais moi aussi je suis un adulte mais on va refaire un TOP 10 !
Non, ce sera sans moi.
OK ! Comme tu veux.
Top 10, For Honor, samouraïs, katanas,
chevaliers, châteaux forts, vikings attaquent à la hache
- Quel gamin...
Je fais des parades et des esquives
- Non mais sérieux quoi...
T'as déjà perdu donc respire
Top 9, Cuphead
Les joueurs sont pas au bout de leur peine
On dirait un dessin animé, c'est mignon
je sais pas pourquoi j'y joue alors que je fais que perdre...
OK, Top 8, Nier Automata
Je suis envoyé sur Terre pour buter des robots de bâtard
avec mon bandeau sous les yeux, c'est compliqué de voir
Du mal à regarder autre chose que mon perso à poil
(Que mon perso à poil)
Bah alors, je croyais que t'avais arrêté les jeux vidéo ?
Bon j'avoue, j'ai joué toute l'année !
Et ton bébé ?
Je l'ai volé à quelqu'un ! Toi aussi ?
Non.
C'est pas le Top 10 des morts les plus stupides, des astuces les plus utiles
Ça non.
C'est pas le Top 10 des mecs les plus balèzes, des plus gros moments de malaise
Mais c'est le Top 10 des meilleurs jeux 2017, des meilleurs jeux de 2017
Des meilleurs jeux de 2017
Top 7, Tekken 7, pas fait exprès
T'appuies sur toutes les touches (You win!) pas fait exprès
Je soigne mon style et ma coupe de cheveux
mais bon j'arrive jamais à caler les coups que je veux
Les coups que je veux
Top 6, Horizon, je suis trop fort,
discret, invisible, inodore
Mais un soir j'ai pris une décision ivre mort
tirer des flèches dans des robots-dinosaures
Top 5, Mario Lapins Crétins
leur monde fusionnent, y'a un pépin
Ils ont donné des armes de ouf à Mario et sa clique
un Mario franco-japonais ça donne un jeu magique
Top 4, Resident Evil 7
dans cette baraque pas évident d'être discret
La famille me tombe dessus je regrette cette enquête
à table au menu, c'est boyaux et rillettes
Top 3, Super Mario Odyssey
je lance ma casquette au pif et
je me transforme en trucs divers et variés
Il me faut vraiment toutes les lunes, obligé
Top 2, PUBG ou Fortnite
à 100 sur la même île, ça part en grosse fight
je veux m'équiper et survivre, le stress est là, faut pas craquer
on a pas réussi à choisir, toi lequel t'as préféré ?
Top 1, Zelda Breath of the Wild
épée, flèche, arc et cotte de mailles
Ganon en Hyrule, étoffe le mal
mais je ferai toujours l'effort de me battre
C'est pas le Top 10 des morts les plus stupides, des astuces les plus utiles
Ça non.
C'est pas le Top 10 des mecs les plus balèzes, des plus gros moments de malaise
Mais c'est le Top 10 des meilleurs jeux de 2017, des meilleurs jeux de 2017
Des meilleurs jeux de 2017
C'est pas le Top 10 des morts les plus stupides, des astuces les plus utiles
Ça non.
C'est pas le Top 10 des mecs les plus balèzes, des plus gros moments de malaise
Mais c'est le Top 10 des meilleurs jeux de 2017, des meilleurs jeux de 2017
Des meilleurs jeux de 2017 #Jambon